cela fait maintenant près de trois mois
que les 230 mille artisans traditionnels
du royaume sont privés de revenus des
tisseurs des fabricants de sacs des
sculpteurs de plâtre ou encore des
potiers qui désespèrent de voir les
touristes revenir je pense qu'après le
court aux navires usines ce métier va
disparaître il n'y a pas de soutien ou
dead il disparaîtra je le dis
sincèrement des artisans traditionnels
qui lance une bouteille à la mer pour
alerter sur le naufrage de leur navire
déjà bien abîmée par la vague de
l'épidémie combler les juges la crise
est passée mais notre situation va
s'aggraver
il n'y a pas de clients pour acheter nos
produits il n'y a pas d'acheteur puisque
les bazars son père mais la crise n'est
pas terminée et pour nous elle durera
encore un an
il faut que l'état vienne en aide à ces
femmes dans la coopérative de la femme
créatrice à salé au nord de rabat une
trentaine de femmes testées tapis
d'ordinaire les tisseuses travaillent
huit heures par jour pour moins de 100
euros par mois
un maigre revenu dont elles sont
quasiment privé depuis que les tapis ne
se vante plus certaines travailleuses
ont pu obtenir des aides directes
débloqués par l'état sur un fond spécial
kovy 19 d'autres n'ont rien eu et ne
parviennent même plus à payer leur loyer
d'après la coopérative
alors les artisans réfléchissent à des
solutions en attendant la fin du
confinement le retour des touristes et
de la clientèle locale
il faut que nous passions à la
commercialisation en ligne
on est obligés aujourd'hui de vendre à
distance puisque le client ne peut pas
se déplacer jusqu ici pour voir et
acheter
donc il faut qu'ils soient servis chez
lui
céramiques bijoux vannerie et meubles en
fer forgé s'entassent dans les échoppes
déserte
en attendant que la vie reprenne son
cours normal il faut dire que
l'artisanat traditionnel contribue pour
7 % au pib du royaume chérifien
avec un chiffre d'affaires à l'export de
plus de 90 millions d'euros l'an dernier
un secteur qui emploie deux millions de
marocains soit 20% de la population
active